here's a uh fascinating story from Yahoo
before we get into the next segment uh
here's the headline are adults over
Halloween costumes nearly two-thirds of
Americans say they aren't dressing up
according to a new Yahoo yugov poll
experts explain why now you got to love
the experts so they brought the experts
in to explain why adults are not wearing
Halloween costumes this year I don't
know what kind of what what field are
these experts in they're experts and how
so it's basic like the experts party
city employees is that are they are they
the experts I don't know maybe we'll
find out the article says Halloween is
around the corner but data from the
latest Yahoo yugu poll suggests that
most us adults won't be Dawning costumes
for the celebration this year according
to the poll while 22% are opting to
dress up for the spooky holiday 63% have
chosen to skip out this season while 14%
have decided uh uh haven't decided one
way or another many of us must must
might find all the hoopla surrounding
Halloween a bit
debilitating for one reason or another
Dr Shina Ali a mental health counselor
and educator who's written about
Halloween okay now we know who the
experts are a mental health counselor
and educator who's written about
Halloween
anxiety which is a thing says that
whether someone loves it or hates it can
often be a sign of something deeper Ali
tells yaho entertainment a big divider
is if the person values Halloween some
of those factors May be related to their
upbringing such as not being from a
family who takes part being part of a
religion with strong beliefs against
Halloween or financial costs for those
who don't have disposable income to
spend on the holiday let's see childhood
triggers aside uh they also say that
this year could be especially tough for
adults who find it hard to have fun
while tragedies are actively occurring
across the globe such as the devastating
Israeli Hamas War
okay sorry there's there's nothing funny
about what's happening uh in the Middle
East but I can't help but laugh at the
image of like a 32-year-old woman
staring at her sexy Frankenstein costume
and saying no I just can't this year I
just can't do it not while there's
conflict abroad not with the conflict
abroad this is not the year to be sexy
Frankenstein maybe regular
Frankenstein it's also funny that the
article is painting the lack of adult
participation in a child's holiday as
some kind of sad thing it's like they're
seeing it as some sort of bad sign about
our culture this is actually one of the
only good signs that we've seen in a
long time this this is one of the only
positive social developments that we
have seen in our culture in
decades if adults aren't wearing
costumes on Halloween maybe it's because
they're adults maybe that's the reason
maybe it's because they're
grown-ups maybe it's because we don't
need to bring experts in okay I don't
need Halloween experts if you tell me
that more and more adults aren't wearing
costumes then that would make me think
maybe I'm being optimistic but that
these adults have looked in a mirror and
said oh I'm an
adult oh oh oh oh I'm 46 years old F and
I've been wearing a Halloween costume
this entire time man that's
embarrassing um now I don't wear a
costume it's not because I have
Halloween anxiety or because I'm
depressed about what's happening in
Ukraine or something it's because I'm a
grown man and it's because Hall costumes
are for children
Halloween is a child's
holiday and if it goes back to being a
child's holiday again that's a good
thing it means that some semblance of
sanity and Order are being restored in
our society in a in a small way but
every bit
counts we still have a long way to go I
mean if two-thirds of adults aren't
dressing up that means that onethird of
adults are dressing up and that's still
way too high and that you know the
numbers are still pretty I mean I met I
went to the other day to the
store uh to get a costume for my son and
he had a costume already but he doesn't
like the one he has so he wanted to get
another one this is how kids are on
Halloween I mean hear about Halloween
anxiety if you're if you're an adult an
adult with Halloween anxiety Then you
need to grow the hell up kids do have
Halloween anxiety though because the the
the decision about what costume to wear
for a kid is like very very important
and they and they go it's a torturous
process of deciding and they changed
their mind 46 times before the actual
night and um I guess we spoil our kids a
little bit because we actually buy them
costumes when I was a kid the costumes
were usually
homemade I've told my kid my kids this
many times it's it's like my version of
the I walk to school both Hill both you
know uphill both ways kind of thing my
version is I had homemade costume they
all they've all heard my speech about
the time when I was a kid and I wanted
to be a night and shining armor armor
and and and uh so my mom made me a a
helmet out of a cereal box
wrapped in tin foil and put that on my
head and said you're in night and
Shining Armor and then I go
trick-or-treating and all night people
are like oh that's a cute astronaut and
I say oh I'm an astronaut I'm holding a
sword okay I get that the helmet's not
exactly it's not exactly historically
accurate but I'm an astronaut with a
sword and then later I realized I should
have just been an astronaut with the
sword because that'd be a way cooler
costume to begin with anyway so I took
my kid to a costume and like 90% of the
costumes were for adults I actually had
to search okay I had to search to find a
costume that is for a
kid and most of those are just
superheroes so like it's if you're a kid
who doesn't want to be a superhero for
on Halloween yeah you you're going to
end up just with a cereal box on your
head wrapped in tin foil because there's
nothing else Pure Talk recently
announced that they would alleviate $10
million in veteran debt by Veterans Day
thanks to your support they are 53% to
that goal with two weeks to go think
about this the US military is made up of
100% volunteers these are men and women
who willingly sacrifice everything they
have for this country when they're done
serving they return home to a tight job
market and outrageous living expenses
that's why I'm so happy a private
company like pure talk has jumped in to
help when you switch to Pure talks
Lightning Fast 5G Network they'll donate
a portion of every new order to this
noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell phone service pure talks plans
start at just 20 bucks a month offering
Unlimited talk text more data and a
mobile hotspot just go to Pur talk.com
Walsh and make the switch let's rally
together and show unwavering support for
our veterans visit Pur talk.com Walsh
and switch to Pur talk today it's the
right move and it's the American way
that's Pur talk.com Walsh today gr Canon
University is an affordable private
Christian University based in Phoenix
Arizona they're dedicated to making
education fit into your already busy
schedule which is why they offer 270 of
their academic programs online from
scholarships to academic support gcu's
graduation team provides you with the
personal support you need to obtain your
goals gcu's online programs offer you
the freedom to earn your degree on your
own time from wherever you are GCU is
praise for its culture of community
giving and impact the integrate the free
market system and welcoming Christian
worldview into all of their academic
programs achieve your goals with a
personalized plan and a supportive team
behind you find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University private Christian
affordable visit gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
I mean imagine going to the playground
okay and and you know the excuse I
always hear is oh well it's fun adults
are having fun I don't care if adults
are having fun you're an
adult what kind of excuse is that it's
like if I I go to the playground and IM
imagine I have to go I go to the
playground my kid has to wait in line
for the plastic slide because there's a
whole line of middle-aged men on the
slide that are using it you know I think
I would be within my rights to be
annoyed by that and to say get the hell
off the playground equipment that's for
kids and I don't want to you know if
they turn around and well we're just
we're we're young at
heart no you're not you're 40 go go go
away the adults are crowding the kids
out of their own spaces their own
holidays because the adults refuse to
grow up and my generation is the worst
with this okay we we we like refuse to
relinquish anything comic books
superheroes cartoons Halloweens we
Halloween we we won't give any of it up
right we're going to bring all of that
to the nursing home with us we refuse to
grow up we just absolutely refuse
because we don't understand that what
the process here is that you enjoy
things as a kid you have your toys and
all of your childlike fun and then you
have kids and you pass that on to them
you don't just cling on to it yourself
your whole
life and then you get to relive it okay
okay I get to relive Halloween like
Halloween's kind of fun now as a parent
not because I'm going trick-or-treating
but because now I am experiencing it
through my kids okay that is how it's
supposed to
work anyway so let the kids dress up and
have their
fun that's the end of my that's my uh
official Halloween speech for the well
we've got a still a week so I've got
more there's more time for more speeches
that we might get to thanks for checking
out this video if you'd like to listen
my full podcast on the go you can check
out the Matt wall show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts